quarter geometry you've been learning
about coins geometry for quite some time
Clym now you probably first encountered
it in your 7 where you had to look at
maps you had to read it and you got to
the basics of how to describe a place on
the coordinate plane and then do some
basic junction with it okay now before
we review some of those ideas and return
to what this thing isn't how to deal
with that through a language for it I
just want to explain before we even
touch the topic what a big deal Corner
John Street is and why it's someone was
in the actual syllabus
okay cool Jory as the name suggests is
about shapes made geometry is when
you're dealing with like triangles and
points and wise you're trying to wrap it
around how they all relate to each other
what kind of patterns in structures you
can see it definitely Yama tree but when
you add cordon to it and you say okay
more than just devoted to draw this more
than just some random triangle hanging
out in the middle of thin air and it has
like some length on or something like
that some angels once you put some
coordinate on it and they actually know
what I'm going to tell you where exactly
this point is and you can understand it
in relation to another point and you can
exactly see where it is in space what
that does is it unites equations which
we've been dealing with earlier today
which was dealing with the use equations
together with shapes then that's really
weird
that's a little bit like can you imagine
if there was like say you know in stray
Leah I don't know how many of you follow
it right with me but you know how
there's the state of origin every year
right is this as well most Queensland
and they're like occupying completely
different sort of say like I'm against
this guy and where we have a really bit
of rivalry people who work with geometry
have a special name they're called are
not your reticence they are called
your geometers right this is a person
whose whole world and job is geometry
and it's a lot more fun you might think
when you do with equations we have these
other guys there
called and another thing addressing
other now for centuries
attend for centuries these guys were
like the blues in the maroon they're
like we have our Lord you have yours and
if anything we've sort of what heads
because we don't like each other it's
like you know we'd love to deal with
shapes and eternal sort of advanced
patterns out there and these guys like
to deal with nitty gritty details and
numbers but what chronic geometry does
is says actually these two really
importantly complement one another
quantity operatory brings equations and
shapes and points and lines together
into one creaking and cold that's why we
spend time on this okay so I want us to
try to remember a little bit about the
language of how for geometry works to go
back to Year seven and this thing now
does anyone remember it has a name
actually it has a French name does
anyone remember what it is yeah jarate
this is called the Cartesian plane can
you offer this lightening up can you
label this the Cartesian plane plane
place not to be confused with the thing
that flies through the air in this
context plane just means something
select okay so if you guys remember when
you're doing woodwork and you're trying
to make something flat you use our place
because you're trying to smooth it all
out and there's a lot whatever wood is
making it swamp okay see that you see
the flat surface so then you'll know
where this comes from no way Cartesian
where that come from
so imagine car if it's fridge it's
actually named after a guy the guy who'd
pioneer working on this anything as you
should let it down
his name is Rene Descartes don't
pronounce that like I used to when I was
in the attempt don't pronounce that
sense Katya
that's not he knows it's French sugar so
Rene Descartes he's famous for the court
if you turned before I think therefore I
am he wasn't just a mathematician here
with into a philosophy and all kinds of
cool stuff but he was the one who really
among the many people who trying to
understand how to use this thing
he was the one after he was named
because he did the most work with it now
on the Cartesian plane there is one
point that is more important that all
the rest of the point is if the origin
so become it's important again so
special name and we label it over for
origin right there in the mentor in
order to describe where you are on the
Cartesian plane you only need two
numbers you know where you are
horizontally and where you are
vertically right so we give the two
things rather than horizontally and
vertically which are really long words
upon two syllables we give them short
names namely X and so you've got an
x-axis that's the horizontal like you've
got a y-axis with a vertical line so
let's observe and if you were to not
just do a plane which is flat but if you
wanted a space with three dimensions
like the one we live in then you would
just have x and y it also has Z which is
sort of coming out of the board and then
you can describe 3d space ok 3d because
there's a next step and why and is that
this is too difficult a yeah just
imagine like just you know have another
and third accesses to come out on board
like that except
my board all right let's put some point
on Pierce so what I want you to know is
we're going to have a scale on you so
I'm going to put a few markings which
I'd like you to also include you've got
a grid mostly this is really easy
so I'm going to put some lines here but
I'm going to say to you right now please
do not mark it all of the numbers on the
Cartesian plane okay for two reasons
number one it will take you forever it
almost certainly you don't need all of
the number then usually only need a
handful okay
secondly not only is a very
time-consuming just to write one two
three
leave one may gives you a cetera it
actually pd's up your diagram and it
becomes difficult to see all the rest of
stuff which is more important okay so
we're just going to label a few
important lives let's pick a point so
for instance if I pick the point say
there and draw that in which is in line
with this sonrisa here and describe how
would we describe the coordinates of
that point I drop it anything yeah yeah
so I'm going to label this let's
actually give it a name as well let's
call design a and it's quite a zoom look
like two comma three because as you can
see you've gone across two units then
you go into three I will point out I
don't know if you started to draw
numbers because I was totally not too
but I did not draw numbers so that might
not be 2 comma 3 it could be like 200
comma 300 I don't have any sense of
scale yet let's do be ported to country
let's put it into scale on there so now
I'm going to mark in the G and now I'm
on the side where you've written
Cartesian plane I want you to make two
little summers okay the first summer it
is when you look at this scale right
scale must be consistent on each axis
let me explain what I mean
you see how we just said that - well
attack - this next point beam is equally
spaced it had better be three three
let's look that's the scale if Ivan said
I was at a point like ten comma one
I can't say it's here because then scale
would be inconsistent along each axis
okay
however while scale must be consistent
bondage activist the scale can be
different on separate axes that's the
plural for answers by the way if spelt
just the same way axis gives that we
printed it axes so you know we're
talking about something different so for
instance just because they're going one
at a time along the x-axis if I wanted
to I could still think this two comma
three hundred and they did 100 200
whatever new so only this consistent by
the growing they can be different to
each other so that makes sense
horizontal vertical doping you separate
in fact sometime they I have to be
really really separate because maybe
this axis here might be that time and
this temperatures over here might be
that temperature it's totally different
years all together let's put another set
of coordinates on here let's go to the
left this time
so I own legal did Queen on the acted
knife I've decided a scale now so
hopefully you guys can tell me what
would that point be what we call it
three it's gone to the left so I do my
horizontal chords first so this is
another cool captivating becoming and
negative three I've gone that way let's
color what what cool so we need
horizontal position first and I'll draw
some top so you can see it'll they're
horizontal positions bus and then we do
very cool seconds right so it does
medical horizontal vertical
X and then Y okay now just really
quickly I will add on what else is
notation on to here you can see the
content of players are broken up into
four regions
different names we call this one up here
you've got another color be helpful we
call this one everything where
everything is positive we call the first
quadrant q ua d ra m t quadrants why do
you think is quite important it's our
one out of four right so there's the
first quadrant you've got the second one
we go a key clockwise second quadrant
over here then the third go x value
negative and you're way down in the
years and then lastly before okay
first second third fourth now it's a
great question as to those who did not
maybe ask okay what is it that this is
the first quadrant
not this one like that's a bit real in
English we write from left to right so
why don't we start over here in them
stays your backwards would anyone like
to suggest for me why actually there's a
good reason why this is a good choice
for the first quarter very big huge okay
so the main thing is when you have a
look at the values of the numbers you're
going to get all the positives over here
and we tend to start there because it's
the easy when you have a look at later
on we're going to attach trigonometry
this you did treat our collages you
thought of how to do if a the try-works
I'm going to attach it to this as well
you will see it as a really common sense
reasoning why starting the top right
even though from English summons maybe
seem like it would make sense
mathematically it doesn't